pour bien se rendre compte de la
violence et de la soudaineté des orages
qui ont frappé hier le nord-ouest du
pays
il suffit de se rendre dans le petit
village d'arc en ville en seine maritime
c'est certainement la commune la plus
sinistrée ce matin avec un mètre d'eau
dans les rues les habitants se sont
réveillés choqué est prouvé par ce
déluge reportage cn breitner pascal peyo
la nuit sans plus n'a pas suffi
ce matin sur la place d'arc en ville il
reste près d'un mètre d'eau tous les
habitants ont été évacués
sauf un couple de retraités qui restait
dans cette maison un ami leur apporte de
quoi se restaurer hier l'eau est montée
jusqu'à 1 mètre 50
ils ont pu se réfugier au premier étage
en bas l'eau a laissé le néo président
et tout détruire et remet le plus plu
énormément puel on est très très gros
vous avez vous avez vu qu'il se
passerait quelque chose de pareil on
affiche une affiche un nettoyage
dérisoire la maison est inhabitable
pourtant ils essayent de s'aménager un
petit coin de vie leur chambre il n'y
toucherons même pas impossible de le
remettre en état
oui tout ça comme un fou autour du café
avec les amis quelques sourires c'est
sûr ils ne partiront pas le nom et aucun
danger
il devrait terminer sa wii la maison d'à
côté dans le même état
le nettoyage a commencé très tôt ce
matin c'était la première fois qu'il
revoyait sa maison à cause de la montée
des eaux
il n'a pas pu la regagner je me suis dit
mon seul rival y avoir de la bouteille
et dans la maison mais à ce point là non
je pense pas pour l'instant rien à faire
dans les sept maisons qui ont été
inondées quant à la ferme elle est en
cornouailles est impossible pour les
pompiers de pomper l'eau ici au centre
du village le niveau est encore beaucoup
trop les sinistrés devront donc
patienter au moins jusqu'à demain si la
pluie ne vient pas aggraver une
situation déjà pénible